[موسيقى]
مساء الخير واحد من اهم التطورات اللي
شاهدها عام 2022 قبل ان يودعنا كان اعلان
اليابان في 16 ديسمبر الماضي عن تغيير
عقيدته العسكريه واعاده بناء القوات
المسلحه بحيث تكون قادره على مواجهه
التهديدات والحروب التي قد تقوده ضد ثلاث
دول على وجه التحديد هذه الدول الثلاثه
الصين وروسيا وكوريا الشماليه
وذكركم انه الجيش الياباني اللي تاسس
بشكله الحالي عقب هزيمته في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه سنه 1954 بيسمى بقوات
الدفاع الذاتي
الجيش وفقا للدستور والماده تسعه منه بينص
على ان اليابان تلتزم فقط بمهام دفاعيه
ولا تسعى ابدا لامتلاك اسلحه هجوميه ولا
تبادر ابدا بالهجوم على اي من جيرانها ليه
الدستور الياباني نص على هذا الكلام على
الطبيعه الدفاعيه للجيش الياباني لان
اليابان بعد هزيمتها في الحرب العالميه
تعلمت درس القاسيا جدا وكان لديها مش بس
لانها خسرت الحرب العالميه الثانيه ولكن
لان لديها ارث دموي استعماري في كثير من
البلاد المجاوره منذ نهايه القرن 19 كانت
بتجاري فيه القوى الاستعماريه الاوروبيه
ولكن في محيطها الاسيوي فقررت ان تنبض
الحرب وان تلتزم بالسلام وبذلك اصرت
الحكومات
اليابانيه المتعاقبه على ان تلتزم بتخصيص
واحد في المئه فقط من
ناتجها المحل الاجمالي لميزانيه الدفاع
طبعا ده رقم كبير برده مش قليل لانه
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لليابان بيتراوح
منذ سنوات من اربعه ونصف الى خمسه تريليون
دولار يعني بنتكلم على حدود 50 مليار
دولار لكن ال 50 مليار دولار تذهب الى
اسلحه دفاعيه فقط قبل 16 ديسمبر 2022
بعد هذا التاريخ الحكومات الحكومه
اليابانيه عبرت عن التغير في عقيدتها
العسكريه
من خلال ثلاثه وثائق رسميه
الوثيقه الاولى المعروفه باسم استراتيجيه
الامن القومي الجديده حددت المشكله
والوثيقه الثانيه هي خطه الدفاع وعرضت
الحلق والوثيقه الثانيه الثالثه حددت
تفاصيل تمويل خطه الدفاع
استراتيجيه الامن القومي الجديده بتعرض
بمنتهى البساطه حجم المشكله
اللي دفع اليابان الى تغيير عقيدتها
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه دي باختصار بتقول
ان اليابان بتواجه بيئه عدائيه جدا وانه
هذه البيئه العادئيه فيها اخطار متعدده
بتاتيها من ثلاثه مصادر محدده
الثلاث مصادر محدده دول هم الصين وروسيا
وكوريا الشماليه
وبناء عليه بترصد كل الادوات او بالوثيقه
بتنص على ضروره ان ترصد اليابان وتستعد
بكل الادوات الدبلوماسيه والاقتصاديه
والسياسيه والعسكريه لمواجهه الاخطار
المحتمله
الوثيقه الثانيه اللي هي خطه الدفاع عباره
عن خطه مدتها 10 سنوات
بتنص على ضروره اعاده هيكله القوات
المسلحه بحيث تكون قوات الدفاع الذاتي
بافرعها الثلاث الجويه والبريه والبحريه
لها قياده متكامله
وتسعى لتعزيز القدرات العسكريه لكل الاصرع
الثلاثه الرئيسيه بالاضافه الى زياده قوه
الفضائيه يكون عندها اسد او اصول في
الفضاء على راسها طبعا اقمار صناعيه
عسكريه
وتزيد من قوتها وقدرتها على خوض حروب
صيبانيه او الكترونيه وطبعا ده معناه في
النهايه ان هي تمتلك اسلحه هجوميه هم ما
بيقولوش اسلحه هجوميه هم بيسموها كاونت
رسترايك او اسلحه الهجوم المضاد ليه ما
بيسموهوش الاسلحه الهجوميه هجوميه لانه
الماده التاسعه من الدستور بتمنع اليابان
من هذا حتى هذه اللحظه انما بتحايل على
المساله دي بان هم سموها كاونت رسترايك او
هجوم اسلحه الهجوم المضاد
وعشان تتخيلوا الفرق ما بين الاسلحه
الدفاعيه والاسلحه الهجوميه اعطيكم امثله
على نوع الصواريخ اللي بتمتلكها اليابان
الان ونوع الصواريخ التي تطمح وبدات في
انتلكه منذ 16 ديسمبر الماضي اليابان اللي
خطتها كانت دفاعيه ممكن انتهاء الحرب
العالميه الثانيه بتعتمد على حمايه حدودها
على صواريخ اقصى مدايتها 200 كيلو متر ما
يعني انها سوف تستهدفه عدوا يقترب من
مياهها الاقليميه ومن حدودها بشكل مباشر
200 كيلو متر يصعب جدا ان تضرب اي من
الدول التي تمثل عليها خطرا في عمقه
بعد هذه الوسيله بعد هذه الوثيقه او بعد
هذا التغير بدات اليابان تستطلع فرص شراء
اسلحه طويله المدى ومتوسطه المدى منها
صواريخ طوما حق الامريكيه
لباس المداء الى اكثر من 1600 كيلو متر
وبتحاول الحصول على 500 صاروخ منه وهي
عندها تصور انه بدايه يجب ان تمتلك 1000
صاروخ من بدايات المتوسطه وطويله
تعاقدها على اسلحه من دول مختلفه مرحله
اولى الى ان تتمكن اليابان من تطوير
قدراتها الذاتيه الدفاعيه وذكركم طبعا ان
اليابان بلد لديه قاعده الصناعيه هائله
جدا
وايضا مش مش فقط ليه الصناعات البدنيه
ولكن للصناعات العسكريه هو فقط لم يكن
يرغب لم يكن اليابانيين يرغب في همم يعني
انتاج اسلحه هجوميه اما وقد قرروا تغيير
عقيدتهم العسكريه اذا سوف يبداهم ايضا في
تطوير صناعات همم
لصناعات او اسلحه هجوميه تيسموها هجوميه
سموها كاونترا سترايك لكن النتيجه ان
هيكون عندهم اسلحه قادره للوصول الى عمق
الدول التي تمثل خطرا عليهم
المساله لا تقتصر على الصواريخ احنا
اليابان بدات تتعاقد او تعاقدت بالفعل على
طائرات اف 35 اللي هي اكثر مقاتلات
الولايات المتحده تطورا وتعقدت مع النرويج
على صواريخ جو همم ايضا متطوره جدا
لتستخدمها في طائراتها اف 35
وتعاقدت مع بريطانيا
وايطاليا لتصنيع مقاتله متطوره من الجيل
الخامس وربما اكثر تطورا من الجيل الخامس
وهكذا هذا عن استراتيجيه او عن خطه الدفاع
اذن الوثيقه الاولى حددت المشكله الوثيقه
الثانيه خطه الدفاع عرضت الحل وخطواته
يتبقى اهم شيء وهو التمويل
والتمويل رئيس الحكومه تعهد بانه ينتقل من
نسبه الواحد في المئه المقدسه منذ انتهاء
الحرب العالميه الثانيه الى اثنين في
المئه من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي هذا تطور
ضخم جدا لانه معناه ان اليابان سوف ترصد
نحو 100 مليار دولار سنويا
لميزانيتها العسكريه هذا رقم كبير يجعلها
من اكثر الدول العالم انفاقا على السلاح
وهتبقى اكثر تفوقا من حيث الانفاق على دول
كبيره عسكريه زي روسيا اللي كان دائما
ميزانيه العسكريه تتراوح ما بين ال 65 و70
مليار دولار
ال- اليابان همم همم لما تحدثت او تحدث
رئيس حكوماتها حكومتها عن زياده الانفاق
من واحد الى 2% كان هذا على يقصد هذا على
المدى البعيد على المدى المتوسط هو قرر
انه
يخصص ما يعادل بالدولار الميزانيه بالهند
طبعا 320 مليار دولار للميزانيه الدفاع
على السنوات الخمس المقبله بدايه من هذا
العام ما يعني 320 على خمسه يعني حوالي 64
مليار دولار سنهويا ده زياده عن متوسط
الميزانيه الثانويه اللي سبقت هذا العام
اللي هي في حدود 50 52 باكتر من 25 في
المئه يبقى السؤال لماذا هذا التغيير الان
يعني اذا كانت البيئه همم المحيطه
باليابان عدايه فهذه البيئه العادئيه
موجوده منذ سنوات فما الذي تغير اليابان
او الوثيقه الاولى اليابانيه حددت السبب
التي دفعها
لتغيير عقيدتها العسكريه
السبب موجود في وثيقه الامن او
الاستراتيجيه الامن القومي الجديده وبتقول
باختصار كده في يعني الصفحات الاولى انه
البيئه الامنيه في اليابان قاسيه ومعقده
كما كانت من الحرب العالميه الثانيه ده
صحيح لكن ايه اللي جد اللي جد انه روسيا
انتهت طبعا الروسي باعتبارها دوله كبيره
انتهت ان النظام الدولي المستقر منذ
انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه بغزها
لاوكرانيا وهذا يعني ان هذا الانتهاك يمكن
ان يتكرر في منطقه المحيط الهادي
والهندي اللي هي المنطقه التي تعنيها بشكل
رئيسي وخصوصا منطقه شرق اسيا افتح قوسين
تقصد ان الصين يمكن ان تكرر ذلك في غزوها
لي تايوان
اضف الى ذلك ان هناك ده هي بتقول كده في
وثيقته ان هناك تغيرات جذريه وتاريخيه في
موازين القوه من دول تسعى لتغيير النظام
القائم لصالحها باستخدام القوه في اشاره
الى الدول الثلاث اللي هي الصين وروسيا
وكوريا الشماليه
السبب الاخير انه هناك عمليه حشد وبناء
للقوات المسلحه للدول المجاوره بشكل يهدد
اليابان ايضا في اشاره الى الدول الثلاثه
وتحديدا كوريا الشماليه اللي بتهدد
باستخدام السلاح النووي ضد الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها في المنطقه وعلى راسها
هؤلاء الخلفاء طبعا اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
اذا نحن عندنا ثلاث خطر على اليابان الصين
روسيا كوريا الشماليه وكل دوله من دول
عندها مشاكل عميقه مع اليابان اذا بدانا
بالصين طبعا الصين زي الدول كثيره اخرى في
شرق اسيا لديها ارث يعني يسمم العلاقه بين
اليابان والصين اليابان دخلت في حروب
مختلفه مع الصين مش في التاريخ البعيد انا
باتكلم فيه التاريخ الحديث باحتلالها من
سوريا في 1931 على ما اذكر ثم حرب اليابان
والصين الثانيه من 37 ل 45 وارتكبت فضائح
هناك هذا احد اسباب توتر العلاقه لكن في
الوقت الحريف العلاقه متوتره بسبب قضيتين
اساسيتين وعشرات القضايا الفرعيه القضيه
الاولى ان هناك خلاف حدودي بين اليابان
وبين الصين في جزر اسمها سنكاكو
يابانيه يعني خاضعه للسياده اليابانيه
الصين بتقول لها واحد ما اسمها السنكاكو
اسمها ضايعي يو وهذه الجزر تخصني ولا
تخصكم وبالتالي هذا اول خلاف حدودي وهذا
يؤرق اليابانيين كثيرا الخلاف الثاني
الرئيسي هو رغبه الصين في استرداد تايوان
اللي بتقول هذه جزء مني ويجب ان يعود الي
سلما او حربا وماذا يعني اليابانيين اذا
استردت الصين قيوان ام لم تسترددها مجموعه
من الاسباب السبب الاول ان طيران حنيف مهم
اقتصاديا وعسكري لليابان والكلاهما يعني
حريفان للولايات المتحده
اذا استردت الصين طيب ان معناها انه
موازين القوه سوف تختل تماما لصالح الصين
التي تمثل تهديدا على اليابان ولو عايزين
تتخيلوا وضع الصين وضع اليابان تخيلوا كده
وضع دول الخليج مع ايران دول الخليج بتشعر
بالقلق من ايران حتى لو لم تسعى ايران في
بعض الاوقات لتبني اي سياسات هجوميه على
دول الخليج مجرد الخلل في موازين القوه
بيشعرها بالخطر
هذا هو السبب الاول الذي يقلق اليابانيين
من غزه الصين لطيران اذا غزوها واستولوا
عليها يحدث اختلال كبير جدا في موازين
القوه ما بين الصين وما بين الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها ثم ان استهلاء الصين على
طيران معناها انها سوف تكون قادره على خنق
كل الامدادات التي تاتيها من الخارج اليها
من مواد خام واا بترول وغاز الى اخره
اضف الى ذلك انه
اذا استولت
الصين على تايوان هذا يعني انه هتكون
الخطوه الثانيه المطالبه بجزر سانتاكو
التي تطالب بها الصين بالفعل اليابان منذ
سنوات
بالمناسبه الصين على مدار عشرات السنوات
الماضيه كان عندها خلافات حدوديه كثيره
حسمت بدات هي بالخلافات الحدوديه
وحسمت كل خلافاتها باستثناء خلاف واحد مع
الهند وده تحدثنا عنه في حلقه سابقا الان
هي بتتفرغ له حسم صراعاتها البحريه واحد
من اهم صراعاتها البحريه هي خلافها على
جزر سنكاتو وطبعا محاوله استرداد تايوان
فليابان تدرك انسدت الصين
قطعا سوف تسعى لاسترداد جزر سنتاكو السبب
الاخير اللي بيقلق اليابان كثيرا من
محاوله الصين او تهديد الصين بغزوهان هو
انها حتى لو لم تكن تشعر بالقلق لكل
الاسباب الماضيه فهي تعلم انه الولايات
المتحده على الارض سوف تتحرك عسكريا
للدفاع عن طيران واذا الولايات المتحده
عسكريا فلا يمكن ان تضل اريابان بعيده عن
هذا الصراع لاسباب كثيره جدا لكن ابسطها
ان الولايات المتحده في الغالب سوف تستخدم
جزر او قواعدها العسكريه في اوقناوه اللي
هي مقاطعه اوكوناوا اللي هي على بعد حوالي
700 كيلو مترا فقط من الصين واللي بتوجد
فيها نصف القوات الامريكيه الموجوده في
اليابان ام متوسط عدد القوات الامريكيه
الموجوده في اليابان وبتضع ترسانه ضخمه
جدا من الاسلحه منها اسلحه نوويه حوالي
50,000 نصفهم في اكوا ناوه معنى كده انه
على الارجح سوف تستخدم القوات المسلحه
الامريكيه الاراضي اليابانيه للرد على
الصين ما يجعل من اقناعه والاراضي
اليابانيه الاخرى هدفا ايه مفهوما جدا
للصواريخ والضربات الصينيه
الدوله الثانيه اللي بتمثلها مصدر التهديد
هي روسيا روسيا السبب الرئيسي لتوتر
العلاقه هو انه هناك خلاف حدودي على جزر
الكوريل الجنوبيه ودي لها قصه طويله يمكن
ان نعود اليها لكن باختصار جزر الكوريل
اللي هي تقريبا غير مقبوله يعني هي جزر
ممتده ما بين حدود روسيا وحدود اليابان
استولى عليها الاتحاد السوفيتي وطبعا هو
عنده اصلا كلاينز او ادعاءات لها يعني
تاريخيه وبعد ان وضع يده عليها بعد انتهاء
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ضمها الى روسيا
الاتحاديه ولم تخرج منها روسيا حتى الان
انتهت رسميا العدائيات اليابان كانت تحارب
الاتحاد السوفيتي في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه انتهت العلائيات رسميه في منتصف
الخمسينات اظن سنه 56
باتفاق لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتوقع
اليابان مع روسيا الاتحاد يا اتفاق سلام
رسمي بسبب مطالبه اليابان بهذه الجزر جزر
كورال الجنوبيه وروسيا كانت وما زالت تقول
لليابان توقعي معاهده سلام لا توقعي
معاهده سلام لن تعود لك قصر كورال ابدا
لان القذر غوريل الجنوبيه بالغه الاهميه
استراتيجيه لروسيا وتضع عليها اسلحه منها
قصه 300 مش بس علشان تواجه اليابان حريف
الولايات المتحده ولكن علشان تواجه القوات
الامريكيه ال 50,000 جندي المدججين باسلحه
منها اسلحه نوويه وقد تستهدف روسيا في اي
وقت
زادت التوترات بين روسيا واليابان بعد
غزوه روسيا ليه همم اوكرانيا في العام
2022 ببساطه لانه اليابان انضمت الى
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها الاخرين في فرد
عقوبات على روسيا وبالتالي بطلت العلاقه
اكثر اكثر البلد الثالث هو كوريا الشماليه
وطبعا الخلافات بين كوريا الشماليه
واليابان كثيره جدا اهم السبب هي ما يسمى
بالحوز او القضايا التاريخيه لان اليابان
احتلت شبه الجزيره الكوريه من
1910 قبل كده كانت محميه يابانيه ثم
احتلتها من 1910 ل 1945 ولم تخرج منها الا
بعد هزيمتها في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وفي ال 35 سنه دي ارتكبت اليابان فضاء ضد
كوريا الشماليه ضد كوريا الجنوبيه قبل ان
تقسم وطبعا القضيه المشهوره جدا قضيه
العماله القصريه اكثر من 700,000 كوري تم
استخدامهم في اعمال السخره من جانب الجيش
الياباني واكثر من 200,000 سيده واستخدمه
كسكس سليبس او بيسموهم كمفرنت سيدات
للمتعه للجنود اليابانيين
ودي قضيه تركت جرحا عميقا في قلوب
الكوريين سواء كوريا الشماليه او كوريا
الجنوبيه لكن المساله لا تقتصر على البعد
التاريخي لان التاريخ ما زال مستمرا على
الاقل بالنسبه لكوريا الشماليه ما زالت
كوريا الشماليه مهدده بعمليه عسكريه وغزو
وضرب عسكريه من الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
في المنطقه مين اهم حلفاءها اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه ولذلك كوريا الجنوبيه
دائما
بتستهدف اليابان في اا يعني مخططاتها
العسكريه في 2000 22 الجاري اطلقت كوريا
الشماليه 92 صاروخا
حتى منتصف ديسمبر
الجاري يعني معظمها كان في اتجاه اليابان
وبتهدد باستخدام السلاح النووي لها في
حاله تعرضها الى هجوم من الولايات المتحده
او كوريا الجنوبيه اللي في الغالب سوف
تنضم اليه اليابان على كل الاحوال هذه هي
المصادر التهديد الرئيسه اللي زادت في
الفتره الاخيره ليه زادت في الفتره
الاخيره ده مرتبط مش بمنطقه همم يعني همم
شرق اسيا ده مرتبط بالتغيرات العالميه
تغيرات العالميه اللي بتشهد مزيدا من
الصراع ما بين الصين وروسيا والولايات
المتحده
واسراعهم على مسارح كثيره في العالم
وبالتالي زاد الالتهاب وزادت فرص الصراع
لما زاد الصراع ما بين القطبين الصين
وروسيا والولايات المتحده دوله زي كوريا
الشماليه وجدت هناك مساحه واسعه واا فرصه
ان هي تطور قدراتها
وهي امنه على نفسها من انها لن تفرض عليها
عقوبات جديده من مجلس الامن لان روسيا
والصين اللي في حاله اعداء مع الولايات
المتحده لن توافق على التمرير اي عقوبات
جديده ولن ولن تفرض عليها عقوبات حتى بشكل
غير مباشر خارج الامم المتحده طيب هذه
القصه طيب نرجع ونقول انه ماذا يترتب على
تغيير عقيده اليابان العسكريه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده في اخبار طيبه واخبار
سيئه الاخبار السيئه انه هذا يعني انه
نفود الولايات المتحده تراجع
وان وهي قدرتها على فرد النظام العالمي
اللي ارسلته منذ الهيئه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه يتم تداعيه ويعني انهياره ليه لان
اليابان كانت غير راغبه في التسلح لانها
كانت واثقه من المظله العسكريه التي
تحميها وتحمي باقي الحلفاء في منطقه شرق
اسيا مثل باقي الدول العالم معنى انه
اليابان تبدا في تسلح والاستعداد للحرب
بنفسها هذا يعني انها لم تعد وثقه من قدره
الولايات المتحده على حمايتها هذا خبر سيء
لكن الخبر الايجابي انه دخول اليابانبه
هذا يعني انها دعم قوي جدا للولايات
المتحده على مستوى الاقتصادي والعسكري
والدبلوماسي في مواجهه التحدي الكبير الذي
ياتي الولايات المتحده من الصين ومن روسيا
هذا اذا طلت المصالح متطابقه بين اليابان
والولايات المتحده وهذه قصه اخرى يطول
شرحها
لكن بالنسبه للصين وروسيا وكوريا الشماليه
هذا خبر سيء لان ده معناه زياده التحديات
اللي بتواجهها هذه الدول من جانب الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها بظهور عنصر جديد اليابان
بكل حولها وطولها لما تدخل حلبه الصراع
بتزيد المخاطر عليهم بشكل كبير
الخلاصه انه رغبه اليابان في تغيير
عقيدتها العسكريه وولدت بسبب زياده
الصراع بين القوه الكبرى والنتيجه انها
سوف تزيد من التهاب هذا الصراع ومعه ان
شاء الله يكون لنا حلقات الاخرى باذن الله
اشكركم والى اللقاء